now to ukraine in a new effort by russia
to cut ukrainian supply lines russian
missiles hit at least five train
stations as ground forces from both
sides battle for control of the eastern
part of the country now this morning
russia's foreign minister blamed ukraine
and the west for the war that his
country started and he once again raised
the possibility that nuclear weapons
could be used charlie daggett is in
ukraine with more on that part of the
story charlie good morning to you
good morning to you gail the russian
military says it struck 90 targets
overnight killing 500 ukrainian soldiers
and destroying dozens of vehicles that
can't be independently verified but it's
clear that fighting has intensified
along the front line
there's been no rest for the
firefighters of harkee
ukraine's second largest city has been
among the hardest hit in the past 24
hours of russian bombardment
a shell-shocked and bewildered 94 year
old woman asks whether the war is over
it's the latest onslaught from a russian
advance stretching along a 300 mile
front line in the east
some of those who managed to escape the
fighting head here to a shopping center
in zapposia
it's the reality of a country at war
that you can buy fabric softener in one
aisle have a refugee tent in the parking
lot and a cafe that's been turned into a
first aid center
fedor zubkov says he lost his wife in
russian shelling and is now struggling
to cope mentally
we started dating when we were 15 years
old he said she was my first love
at a nearby military hospital we find
the zika team after stepping forward to
fight when the war broke out the 27 year
old radio host from levi found himself
right in the middle of the most brutal
frontline fighting in the donbass region
an artillery round on saturday tore
through both legs and his arm did you
think maybe
you weren't going to survive
i thought i lost my leg and wouldn't be
able to play soccer he said first thing
i asked was whether i could play soccer
and fight again
you want to fight again yeah of course
of course of course because it's my land
it's my country
it's my motherland
we asked whether he told his mother how
badly wounded he was he said not yet he
didn't want to worry her and she's a
type of person to drive more than 600
miles from la vie to the front lines to
come see him
jamie
sounds like a lot of moms charlie in
ukraine thank you